Joshua is with us from British Columbia
hi Joshua how are you yes sir how can I
help
yes I'll try and keep it straight to the
point
I've been living in my car on and off
for about two months I was homeless for
about two weeks with my car had broken
down and I'm just wondering money has
become one of my biggest stresses and
I'm just curious what advice you have
some never but in this situation again
like my family is a financially stable
to support me we've always struggle with
money I'm currently working to
restaurant jobs one of them just caught
my shifts and the other one I don't
think a ton of tips as a service but I'm
just wondering I'm 23 years old at this
point in life I don't really want to
ever be in the situation because my
physical health spiritual health mental
health it's all going down since I lost
my hold himself just wondering for some
advice as far as what to do and how to
prevent that happening again yeah so
you're single yeah okay and when did you
leave your parents home well I've been
living um what happened is I been on my
own for about a year and a half but I
moved to BC and once I got the BC I was
in a car accident my money that I had
for our place went towards my vehicle to
fix my vehicle and then it was right in
the middle of summer and I wasn't able
to secure work until shortly about maybe
a month later I was living in a homeless
shelter and now recently the homeless
shelter I've extended my stay life it's
been a month
but where is home yeah I parked by the
ocean and I don't need where do your
parents live my mom was about three
hours away but she has a boyfriend going
through cancer from me being there isn't
really it's very tough I guess tough
living in a forest all my belief and
health issues right yeah living in your
car is tough they don't have another bed
laughs I mean you don't take up much
space as long in an RV
like a small army so they're basically
homeless too but you know okay but yes I
guess basically where does she live
she lives in a Parksville I live in
Victoria so it's about a two and a half
three hour drive away from each other
okay well I mean I mean there's two
there's two aspects of this there's a
short-term aspect in the long-term
aspect the short-term aspect is getting
you out of your car getting you into
some income and getting you into you
know some basic shelter and getting you
back getting your feet under you that's
aspect one and then aspect to is what
you're asking about which is once you
get that going then what we do from
there to ensure that you're never back
again okay so I want to revisit part of
the conversation because I'm trying to
get into your brain and see how you made
the decisions to do this so you use the
money that was going to be used for you
to have a place to stay you know in a in
an apartment to fix your car so instead
of being car less you chose homeless so
what had occurred was I was in parks
well I'm Park Hill is a very small town
so I wasn't able to find work because it
was in the summer so everybody was
already very over staff so I for me to
find work I had to have a vehicle to try
it down to Victoria to be able to secure
somewhere so I've been working in two
restaurants at the moment mm-hmm so in
the event that I would have used the
money to get a place I wouldn't have had
transportation to get to in somewhere I
guess they don't know there's no buses
that drive from a bus ticket wouldn't
have gotten you to the place you're
going you're living now
and Scientology's no well being was an
early like where it was supposed to be
like down under the car then I went
really emotionally laughs yeah so part
of how you got here I guess is my point
is not necessarily jobs or even
financial it's just bad decision-making
and I'm not sure I'm not trying to shame
now with that I'm just trying to say I
want to analyze how you got here so we
never get here again and that's what I'm
trying to do with you okay and so what
we've got to do is say okay when in
doubt we have a place to live so the
second thing that keeps coming up is
there's no jobs there's no jobs there's
no jobs I don't know anything about
British Columbia in terms of jobs now I
have a new job yeah but they suck yeah I
mean you're making any money and so I
know that if you were in Nashville what
I would tell you to do is take your last
50 dollars and go buy a leaf blower rich
people are afraid of leaves you know I
mean you can you can find so you can go
create work right I mean I had a young
man knock on our door with a pressure
washer and he's he's pressure washing
driveways and paying for his tuition to
go to college and so there's work to be
done that's up pays a whole lot more
than 10 hours a week as a server with
bad tips in your situation and so I got
to do something to create income here
and it's probably some kind of
self-employed unpleasant thing that you
do for a little while but that pays
really good I mean for a short term I'll
have you clean out septic tanks with a
toothbrush if it pays good to get you
some money okay because right now in the
short term you need money right that's
what we're doing and I've done all those
kinds of things under done septic tangle
toothbrush but I've done everything else
okay you know cut grass and haul trash
away and shoveled stuff and I've done
all that kind of stuff and and honestly
you can get people doing that kind of
stuff for them to pay you better than
then you can make six dollars an hour
somewhere you know and so what happens
is you're spending a lot of your effort
trying to analyze the local job economy
and get jobs that suck and I'm trying to
think of how we can get you working all
like your car running yeah my cars
running and you deliver pizzas there I
think probably make more money serving
like again I don't know British Columbia
but everywhere else you deliver pizzas
if you'll do that like five six seven
nights a week you can make $2,000 a
month and we can get you in an apartment
yeah yeah you are like 1,500 to 2,500
dollars of income by the end of it I'm
not too sure how much my rent
okay then you need to go investigate
that and get the cheapest possible place
you can with six roommates split into
six ways and create your own little
hostel there and let's let's get off the
street and then let's take another step
up and then let's take another step up
and then let's take another step up but
this is all about how fast and how much
income you can create by just going
crazy I want you working like all the
time you anything else to do and make
some money and that's where I start you
all right then I think you can begin to
turn it around you call me back if I can
help you more but that's what I'm
hearing listening to you I think you got
potential dude this is the Dave Ramsey
show
[Music]